and we're gonna begin here this morning
we're getting a closer look at the site
in Greece where an American scientist
was found dead Greek police tell CBS
News they're conducting DNA tests on
several people in connection with the
murder of Suzanne Eaton Holly Williams
is in Crete where Eden was attending a
conference Holly what more have we
learned
good morning the place where Suzanne
Eaton's killer or killers attempted to
hide her body is just through this olive
grove but the Greek police still will
not confirm whether they have any
official suspect it's a macabre place
the dank Nazi bunker from World War two
where they discovered Suzanne Eaton's
body Greek police told CBS News the
American biologist was suffocated to
death well this place can only be
described as a kind of underground maze
a complex of tunnels a labyrinth if you
will
and local officials have told us that
they believe that Suzanne Eaton was
killed elsewhere and then her body was
placed or dumped inside this complex of
bunkers the forensic pathologist who
carried out the post-mortem told us her
death was far from quick there are
reports in the Greek media that she had
knife wounds she may have been tortured
can you comment on that coming through
at night had she been sexually assaulted
I come on the Fresno we're looking
forward
you know maybe my DNA Suzanne Eaton was
an extraordinary individual by any
measure an award-winning scientist keen
sports woman accomplished pianist
and mother of two sue is too great a
person for her legacy to be defined in
any way by how we lost her her sister
said in a statement a strong kind
brilliant selfless human being when she
disappeared Tuesday last week her family
offered a reward for help in finding her
now Caterina Kahala Zampa is helping
care for her sons and husband at the
Academy where Suzanne was attending a
conference we saw the family coming and
being very much touched by this but also
having all the strength to go on till
the end to find their mother Crete is a
peaceful place it is steeped in ancient
Greek mythology and the locals here are
horrified by this killing of a guest on
their Island
Anthony Polly Williams in Crete thank
you yeah an extraordinary woman and a
real mystery here